قدم مزيج من الشخصيات بين الكوميديه
والشريره والمبكيه عاشق المسرح نضال
الشافعي هو ضيف اليوم تسلط الضوء على
الجانب الانساني من الفنان اللي في ناس
كتير ممكن تشوف ان حياته ومرفعه وما عندوش
مشاكل بعض الناس يتخيل انه حياه الفنان هي
انبساط سعاده فلوس كتير شهره كتير كلام
كتير كفته قليل اتحولنا فروله على قد ما
نقدر ان احنا نوضح انه الفنان بني ادم
عنده مشاكله وعنده
مشاكله السخيفه ومشاكله القويه ومشاكل
ومشاكله اليوميه ومشاكله الزوجيه
على الجمهور مسلسل تامر وشوقيه كانت
ادوارك الاكثر بتاعها كوميدي دلوقتي
الادوار بتاعتك اغلبها شر بصي اقول لك
حاجه انا بشكرك والله على اسئلتك انت واضح
فنانه وعندك مخزون عظيم يعني فبتعرفي تخشي
في خبايا الممثل كده بص هقول لك اللي يخاف
من الديب يطلع له
وفي احد وفي احد المحافظات يعني ايه اللي
يخاف من العفريت يطلع له تمام هي الفكره
ايه انا لما كان بدايتي فكره الكوميدي مع
تامر وشوقيه والتفاصيل دي وقعدت خمس سنين
بقدمها كان كل خوف ان انا اتحط في القالب
ده كنت طول الوقت بحاول اهرب من فكره ان
انا اتحط في قفص او صندوق بتاع فكره
المضحكات بس يعني هتبدا يضحكنا ده يعيطنا
هاتوا ده يغمنا فرحت للادوار المركبه ودخل
فيها الادوار الشريره والحمد لله بفضل
ربنا علي وتوفيقه الادوار دي لقت نجاحنا
لقت مشاهده لقت توفيق كبير من عند ربنا
وكل ما كان بيجيني دور كنت ببقى سعيد من
السكه دي لان انا خلاص القالب اللي انا
كنت خايف احط نفسي فيه بعدت عنه فمن غير
ما اقصد ومن غير ما اللي يخاف من العفريت
يطلع له حطوني في حته معينه